quando mi hanno invitato a parlare qui
altezza e ho cominciato a girare per la
città perché da qualche tempo che vivo
schio e ho visto queste hicks in giro
per la città e all'inizio non sapevo
neanche si riferissero al ted ma mi
hanno fatto venire in mente
un'esperienza devo dire alla fine molto
bella che mi ha anche un po ha segnato
da un punto di vista caratteriale cioè
la mia partecipazione come autore per
vii edizione di xfactor e qui insomma
guardando la ics abbastanza semplice
allora mi è venuto in mente che che in
tutte quelle edizioni quando io
assistevo assieme a morgan perché
lavorava a stretto contatto con organo
come il suo autore collaboratore mi sono
visto in sette edizioni una valanga di
provini di questi ragazzi che venivano
con la grande convinzione con una specie
di inconsapevolezza rispetto a quello
che doveva succedere che cosa avrebbero
fatto perché fondamentalmente loro
venivano lì per diventare famosi
quindi loro arrivavano extra io voglio
diventare famosa
allora guardando questi ragazzi alcuni
più bravi altri meno
mi sono sempre chiesto ma che cos'è
questa hicks questa hicks che gli autori
questo fattore hicks legato alla musica
gli autori originali quelli inglesi dell
xfactor ci hanno sempre detto che lei
rappresenta qualcosa che noi chiameremo
il talento ma guardando bene questi
ragazzi tutti questi ragazzi avevano un
talento e soprattutto tutti avevano un
talento o alcune avevano un talento
specifico per la musica e soprattutto
questa hicks se si tratta di talento è
qualcosa di sconosciuto mi sono chiesto
io perché andando indietro nel tempo
negli anni della scuola delle scuole
superiori
mi ricordo le equazioni di primo grado
cioè se uno fa hicks meno uno uguale a
zero l'aics sappiamo benissimo che cosa
non è che è una cosa incognita
si chiama di incognita perché ci devo
arrivare in locazione di primo grado è
molto semplice
però se faccio x140 sappiamo bene che
cos'è la ics e allora mi è venuto in
mente che i fondatori di xfactor
sapevano bene cosa stavano cercando cioè
non cercavano qualcosa di sconosciuto
come per esempio secondo me è la
bellezza e il genio che è qualcosa di
incomprensibile di inafferrabile ma
cercavano qualcuno un talento ben
specifico cioè una ics che aveva un
valore allora osservando questi ragazzi
mi veniva in mente tutti questi ragazzi
avevano una caratteristica e soprattutto
quelli che venivano presi avevano una
caratteristica ragazzi che poi come si
dice ce l'hanno fatta
eccole questa caratteristica è la novità
secondo me e cioè qualcosa che in
televisione ha un effetto di
intrattenimento molto forte spesso per
esempio capitava che i ragazzi avessero
addirittura dei difetti mi ricordo nello
specifico un ragazzo che balbettava e
molto tipico per esempio se c'è qualcuno
che fa il logopedico logopedista fa bene
che la balbuzie interviene in certi
contesti poi se magari un ragazzo
balbuziente canta la balbuzie sparisce e
questo viene questo ragazzo è stato
preso a xfactor perché c'era questo
problema e questo faceva effetto
televisivamente parlando ma questo
ragazzo aveva un talento un talento che
accomunava tutti sicuramente era quella
che io invece chiamo una capacità vocale
cioè tutti avevano il muscolo delle
corde vocali
diciamo più o meno interessante da un
punto di vista di estensione da un punto
di vista timbrico ecco allora questo
benedetto talento
abbiamo visto che non è qualcosa di
sconosciuto perché nel caso di xfactor
se cercavano quello a allora si sapeva
benissimo che cosa era e soprattutto il
talento secondo me a che fare più con
un'abilità che non può qualcosa con
qualcosa di più legato alla bellezza la
parola estetica in filosofia una branca
della filosofia
diciamo che viene da molto lontano il
primo acquazzone stato aristotele ma
forse addirittura qualche peso pratico
la parola estetica viene da una parola
greca che ice thesis che vuol dire
sensibilità
ecco secondo me l'abilità non ha tanto a
che fare con la sensibilità perché
torniamo sempre a qualcosa di ignoto che
nel caso di xfactor è abbastanza
conosciuto ma nel caso invece del del
talento del caso abbastanza conosciuto
ma nel caso della bellezza invece
piuttosto sconosciuto mi viene da fare
anche un altro tipo di esempio
forse fu un po un po fuori dai ranghi io
sono appassionato come tanti di voi di
rock'n'roll del cantautorato eccetera e
quindi quando ascoltato per la prima
volta david bowie per esempio mi sono
accorto che non era soltanto
interessante cioè david bowie non aveva
soltanto soltanto qualcosa che io
conteneva già cioè non mi stava dicendo
qualcosa che io già sapevo non colpiva
la mia immaginazione soltanto ma creava
un immaginario nuovo baby boy era
qualcosa non solo ti sorprendi
interessante ma addirittura di
sorprendente sarà una sorpresa e mi
immagino negli anni 70 chi lo ha visto
per la prima volta quando da vibo v è
diventato famoso vedere questo vestito
in quel modo
gli zatteroni alti così che faceva il
matto che cantava quelle canzoni deve
essere stato veramente una sorpresa non
alieno life on mars infatti ecco quindi
da una parte dei vibo v dall'altra
invece mi viene in mente un personaggio
come gigi d'alessio
io però li metterei insieme perché tutte
e due hanno effettivamente delle
caratteristiche in comune allora
sicuramente direi che gigi d'alessio
almeno nel mio caso che non voglio
offendere la sensibilità di nessuno ma
non trovo che sia così tanto
sorprendente le domeniche d'agosto
quanta neve che cade a quella
effettivamente potrebbe addirittura
essere sorprendente adesso che ci pensa
però diciamo che che se mettiamo insieme
a gigi dove gigi d'alessio vediamo che
c'è una differenza sostanziale e cioè 1
veicolo ha un contenuto molto forte e
personale con una personalità
incredibile che di volta in volta ci
lascia presagire qualcosa di ignoto
cioè non si sa ogni disco di david bowie
era qualcosa di nuovo si riconosceva in
oasi riconosce
voi però sempre molto strano ma i due
talenti si somigliano per un motivo e
soprattutto soprattutto per la per un
talento che io chiamo non artistico come
quello di david bowie ma per un talento
che invece io chiamo comunicativo e la
grande forza di digi d'alessio così come
quella di tanti artisti pop di oggi
soprattutto è quella per l'appunto della
comunicazione e cioè non è più
importante un forte talento non è più
importante che cosa comunicare ma è
importante comunicare e basta
quindi si può anche comunicare il nulla
allora gigi d'alessio che cosa fa
poverino la prendiamo come capro
espiatorio
insomma per capirci lui è molto attento
alle quali sono le esigenze del proprio
pubblico
a differenza di un artista come david
bobée che se ne sbatte va completamente
io conosco bene anche franco battiato
per esempio lui quando gli si chiede ma
franco ma allora interessa sapere se il
pubblico il prossimo disco cioè no non
gli interessa assolutamente perché lui
ha bisogno ea come un'urgenza di
scrivere e di fare quel tipo di musica
di scrivere quel tipo di testi non ha
assolutamente nessun interesse ad
arrivare a un pubblico che capisca
necessariamente ma lui interessa
sorprendere non interessare ecco invece
gigi d'alessio si interessa molto a
proprio pubblico
tutti quelli che scrivono musica
commerciale
cioè che devono veicolare qualcosa che
faccia qualcosa o niente o qualcosa di
assolutamente vuoto per fare i soldi
queste persone devono conoscere che cosa
vuole il pubblico mi è anche capitato mi
capita ancora di vedere degli artisti
coevi anche a noi anche perché la mia
stessa età o anche più piccoli che fanno
questo vedono come si veste il proprio
pubblico o un certo pubblico di
riferimento e al loro volta copiano cioè
quindi se va di moda il pantalone che
dell'adidas con la tuta allora tutti
quanti si vestono in quel modo lì se va
di moda un certo tipo di capigliatura
allora lui come artista si immedesima
nel proprio pubblico e così è più facile
veicolare che cosa niente perché il
pubblico vede qualcosa in cui si
riconosce e gli piace semplicemente è
una forma di talento molto forte ma
allora il talento ora che voglio
arrivare voglio dire questo che spesso
il talento è considerato come una forma
d'arte
quando si dice che a quello di un
talento talento lo vede insomma uno che
ma in realtà no perché il talento
semplicemente come dicevo prima un
abilità ed è molto diciamo è un bomber
sta diventato un po un problema in
questi anni in questi momenti anche
politicamente forse un po difficili
questo perché è sempre di più si tenta
di comunicare qualcosa che non sia un
vero e proprio contenuto ma ma quel
qualcosa è la comunicazione stessa 13 a
una come anche i social network e
instagram facebook ma che cosa fai no io
faccio questo io comunico non non ho un
contenuto vero e proprio da comunicare
ecco mentre la musica dovrebbe
riguardare la bellezza dovrebbe essere
più vicina alla bellezza un contenuto
molto forte e molto importante piuttosto
che semplicemente comunicare qualcosa
che non perché non abbia senso cioè un
anno più vicino a niente ecco non mi
viene in mente niente perché è vicino a
niente
nel 2017
alcuni scienziati 3 euro neuro
scienziati hanno scoperto quelli che si
chiamano i neuroni specchio che cos'è
nerone specchio è sono quei neuroni aver
mai capitato di fare in una stanza con
una persona che magari un vostro caro
amico per una persona della quale siete
innamorata e nello stesso preciso
istante in quel momento di te
contemporaneamente alla stessa parola
questo vuol dire che stavate pensando
l'ho detto la dico in maniera molto
semplice poi insomma lo studio è molto
complesso e molto interessante però
evidentemente in quel momento pensando
alle stesse cose
avendo uno stesso background culturale
avendo la stessa sensibilità per
qualcosa
tutti e due ditte quella stessa parola
in quello stesso momento
ecco lì ci sono i neuroni specchio che
agiscono e fanno in modo che le persone
in qualche modo si interconnettono tra
di loro e succede questa specie di
telepatia fondamentalmente allora
probabilmente quando ho visto ho letto
questo questo articolo sui neuroni
specchio detto bel gigi d'alessio è uno
che ce le ha di brutto questi nuovi
specchio perché se capisci al volo
questa roba qua ed è effettivamente
potrebbe essere vero ecco un vero e
proprio talento io i neuroni specchio li
vedo
li vedo un po come una forma di
innamoramento e se uno è innamorato di
una persona che questa persona vive
dall'altra parte del mondo in australia
e pensa questa questa persona si pensano
molto si sentono anno questo specie di
lega meno e quindi anche se sono così
tanto distanti tra di loro non ricordo
sfruttare ma di dirac forse dice vi
dicevo anche questa cosa qui a un certo
punto
queste persone sono comunque in contatto
tra di loro e questo non è altro che
l'innamoramento questa è una forma di
talento comunicativo molto forte e molto
bella che poi in certi casi come nella
politica nella politica o incerta musica
venga utilizzato per fare soldi e questo
il brutto questo è il problema
ma se uno i neuroni specchio venissero
usati per veicolare invece un contenuto
potente
e incognito è la bellezza è quella cosa
che ci sorprende sempre che ci sovrasta
che inarrivabile no io mi ricordo quando
studiavo estetica
il professore mi spiegava una cosa che
mi faceva bollire dentro il cuore quella
cosa che si chiamava il sentimento del
sublime era come qualcosa che non si
capiva bene cos'è il sublime il fulmine
la tempesta la tempesta interiore il
sublime qualcosa che allora se noi
imparassimo tutti abbiamo i neuroni
specchio a trasferire la bellezza
attraverso i neuroni specchio allora
credo sarebbe un mondo anche meno banale
di quello che a me in questi ultimi
tempi stiamo vivendo in buona pace per
buona pace di gigi d'alessio e devi poi
[Applauso]